[Musique]
bonsoir à tous comme tous les soirs nous
allons échanger des points de vue de
préférences contradictoires sur
l'actualité du jour que je vous propose
de découvrir tout de suite en images
nous allons nous intéresser à nicolas
hulot après l'aveu du ministre de la
transition écologique selon qu'elle est
très difficile de ramener à 50% la part
du nucléaire dans la production
d'électricité d'ici 2025 nicolas hulot
doit tigres en tirer toutes les
conclusions et démissionné de son poste
du gouvernement nous reparlerons de
pierre de villiers et l'ancien chef
d'état major des armées françaises que
l'on voit ici le 19 juillet le jour de
sa démission fracassante pour cause de
désaccord avec le président de la
république pierre de villiers qui sort
aujourd'hui un livre intitulé servir
nous allons nous intéresser aussi à
donald trump qui est assez haut qui a
fait pour ne pas changer des
déclarations fracassantes
aujourd'hui donald trump qui est aussi à
la maison blanche depuis un an est il si
impopulaire que ça finalement peut-être
pas auprès de ses électeurs et c'est
peut-être que à ses yeux il ya que ça
qui compte
nous nous poserons la question et puis
nous reviendrons sur la une de charlie
hebdo consacré à edwy plenel directeur
de mediapart et à ses liens plus ou
moins revendiquer avec tariq ramadan
le prédicateur musulman dans la
tourmente pour cause de nombreuses
plaintes pour harcèlement sexuel et
violent nous allons parler de ces quatre
sujets avec denis tillinac bonsoir denis
cet écrivain journaliste éditeur votre
dernier livre l'âme française est paru
l'année dernière chez albin michel ont
soir alexis lacroix vous saurez vous
vous êtes le directeur délégué de la
rédaction de l'express c'est vous êtes
aussi un contributeur éminent de la
revue la règle du jeu et c'est la
couverture de l'express qui apparaît sur
l'écran consacré à l'enfant wauquiez cet
homme peut-il fédérer la droite telle
est la question que vous posez en
couverture bonsoir guillaume demont jour
vous êtes grand reporter au figaro
magazine claude nous n'augmenterons pas
la couverture car que mercredi
et donc il faudra encore attendre deux
jours avant d'avoir la chance de voir le
projet prochaine livraison et bonsoir me
girard soie c'est bien sûr le
chroniqueur international du figaro on
retrouve aux chroniques chaque mardi et
votre dernier livre qu'elle diplomatie
pour la france prendre
les réalités telles qu'elles sont et
paru aux éditions du cerf parlons si
vous le voulez bien pour commencer de
nicolas hulot
donc hier le ministre de la transition
écologique et solidaire ne l'oublions
pas c'est important la solidarité a dit
ben oui finalement on aurait bien aimé
ramener à 50% la part du nucléaire dans
la production d'électricité en france
en 2025 vous souvenez c'était un
engagement de françois hollande
repris par emmanuel macron mais
finalement dit oui l'eau ça va être
compliqué et le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est que ses petits camarades ne le
ménagent pas ce matin voici un petit
florilège des réactions des politiques
les saisons changent il ya eu le temps
de la campagne électorale maintenant il
ya le temps des réalités j'espère que le
chapeau de monsieur hulot a bon goût
parce qu'il va peut-être que manger
plusieurs fois qu un ministre qui cède
sur les perturbateurs endocriniens sur
le ceta sur le glyphosate maintenant sur
la transition énergétique qui n'avalent
plus des couleuvres qui avale des boas
constrictors nicolas hulot doit rester
nicolas hulot je continue évidemment de
le soutenir mais parfois ils gagnent
parfois il perd il a gagné sur le
glyphosate
il a perdu sur la taxe sur les
transactions financières et hier
clermont à mes yeux il a perdu une
manche
c'est un langage un peu de facilité de
nicolas hulot je trouve cette très
triste parce que c'est lui qui avait un
langage au contraire très volontariste
dans ce domaine je pense qu'il ya des
fois où à défaut de faire noble on peut
faire court je pense que là la décision
de nicolas hulot est une décision de
raison et de sagesse
aujourd'hui nicolas hulot ne mange pas
son chapeau il va animer un groupe de
réflexion il va travailler pour apporter
d'autres types de réponses si celles qui
sont aujourd'hui révélées ne peuvent pas
parce qu'on sait bien de portée des
combats mais c'est bien aussi d'être
pragmatique alors nicolas hulot va-t-il
ou non manger son chapeau est il en
train de faire je vous propose d'écouter
avant de lancer le débat et bien sa
réponse il était ce matin sur le plateau
de nos confrères de bfm tv
c'est important de se fixer des
objectifs ambitieux mais ce qui est plus
important et notamment s'ils n'ont pas
perdre de la crédibilité sur l'ensemble
de notre stratégie énergétique c'est de
regarder la faisabilité de planifier les
choses beaucoup savaient que cet
objectif n'était pas atteignable pas
changé d'avis parce que je suis de
devenu ministre oui et par contre je
peux découvrir la complexité et oui le
nous somme essentielle au pouvoir mais
enfin il nous avons des règles et ne
sommes pas hors droits en ce qui est
intéressant c'est que nicolas hulot dit
beaucoup disaient que c'était difficile
où il y avait même énormément de gens
qui savaient pertinemment que c'était
impossible et pourtant il est allé au
gouvernement est ce que vous pensez
qu'il a fait une erreur
john demongeot vous aviez fait un
portrait de nicolas hulot pour parler de
ses états d'âme on avait été les
promeneurs dans le figaro magazine à les
mentionner qu est il allé faire dans
cette galère ou bien n'ont finalement
c'est le lot d'un ministre d'avaler des
couleuvres de temps en temps mais je
pense que cette loi il ya deux ans était
inapplicable donc dès le départ mais je
pense qu'il ait choisi son timing pour
annoncer qu'elle le cab était-il
impeccable et qu'il fallait différé de
dix ans sa mise en application
on n'a pas besoin de mes objectifs c'est
2035 pour arriver à ce fameux seuil des
50 est ce que c'est si grave la
direction et la l'orientation est prise
ça va dans le bon sens si on n'est pas
en train de la journée complètement la
loi je viens cgdd il souligne juste que
hollande et royal était une équipe
démagogues et qu'elle était complètement
dans des effets d'annoncé spectaculaire
qui était inapplicable
moi je dirais que c'est un homme
tourmenté nicolas hulot c'est la place
et de la pression qui nous a donné quand
on l'a rencontré pour monter toujours un
peu aussi d'en haut mais là il parle de
maintenant d'un an il se donne un an
pour réfléchir à sa présence au
gouvernement je trouve que c'est c'est
vrai qu'avant un an il peut pas avoir
vraiment pris des mesures importantes et
donc il a envie de marquer de laisser
une trace annoncé le bien minimum mais
je dirais que l'un pas besoin de
démissionner pour autant là s'est il est
plutôt dans un diagnostic de réalisme
alors il est réaliste
allez qu'il a quand même peut-être qu'il
aurait pu le dire il ya six mois quand
il est entré au gouvernement que ça
n'allait pas être possible d'écouter oui
c'est vrai bien sûr guillaume est quand
même faisons attention je crois que
ziaya typiquement sur le sujet qui nous
occupe depuis ce matin concernant la
présence de ce ministre disons de
sensibilité écologiste au sein d'un
gouvernement dominé par les figures des
macros nhien et de leurs amis
il ya typiquement je crois un
emballement médiatique
car au fond nous avons nous dans les
médias une manière de considérer
l'articulation de l'éthique de
responsabilité et de l'éthique de
conviction pour les bears sort de ce
corps voilà pour parler comme webber
c'est à dire en gros la défense de ses
idéaux personnel et le service d'un
collectif c'est l'éthique de
responsabilité on a une manière bien à
nous de les considérer et sadek et ça
n'est pas forcément ça n'est pas
forcément la manière qu'il faut avoir
dans quand on est dans une logique
politique
donc je rejoindrai plutôt ma consoeur
sur ce point je pense qu'effectivement
il a raison de d'ouvrir une sorte de
phase ii moratoire sur sa propre
inscription dans ce gouvernement il n'a
pas tout perdu et puis par ailleurs
faisons attention aussi à une forme de
myopie
là encore je dirais journalistique dès
qu'un ministre perd une bataille
essentiellement d'ailleurs face au
premier ministre et au président de la
république dont on sait bien que disons
dans la cinquième revue et corrigée par
macron c'est lui qui centralise toute la
décision c'est une évidence donc dès
qu'un ministre perd une bataille on
pense qu'il doit partir
mais attention ça c'est une opinion
j'allais dire de deux défenseurs d'idées
qui peuvent s'ils sont vraiment en
désaccord avec l'actionnaire par exemple
de leur journal claquer la porte
un ministre il n'est pas forcément dans
cette logique là assez grave pour un non
il n'est pas sur tout site web et
surtout et puis surtout quand on est
journaliste on est d'abord des
défenseurs d'idées de point de vue
d'opinion quand on est ministre on est
on s'inscrit aussi dans un rapport de
force je pense qu'actuellement
effectivement le rapport de force ne met
pas forcément favorable mais en revanche
s'il attend on ne sait pas après tout
peut-être que son inscription dans le
maquereau nisme lui réserve de bonnes
surprises par ailleurs par ailleurs par
ailleurs quand les vrais cher les vraies
réformes les vraies réformes
ça sera le troisième point les vraies
réformes qui souffrent de la faim voilà
ne se font jamais dans le maximalisme
révolutionnaire donc il est possible
qu'en fait en prenant son temps en
bougeant son chapeau provisoirement il
arrive à inscrire sa trace dans
l'histoire des ministres de l'ecologie
beaucoup plus remarquablement que
certains qui avaient fait des effets de
rené girard serez vous aussi indulgent
avec le ministre de la transition
écologique et solidaire
mais oui puisqu'il a constaté ce qui est
du bon sens que si on veut effectivement
réduire l'émission de gaz à effet serre
mais ya pas de l'énergie plus efficace
que l'énergie nucléaire c'est la
première chose deuxième chose c'est que
moi je ne comprends pas pourquoi on ne
fait pas d'énergie nucléaire c'est qu'on
utilise des électrons pour l'électricité
là qui nous éclaire en ce moment même
mais on ne veut pas utiliser la force
qui à l'intérieur du noyau de l'atome
pour ça tout à fait grotesque est ce que
les japonais et j'en parlais récemment
un responsable japonais n'ont pas pris
les mesures de précaution nécessaires au
japon pour fukushima
oui c'est s est avérée mais
effectivement même quand vous quand on
aurait pu on peut dire aussi qu'on ne
veut pas monter dans un avion parce que
c'est beaucoup trop dangereux
maintenant voilà il faut garder
nucléaire parce que c'est pas dangereux
alors que lui dit on le garde parce que
ça met du temps avant de trouver
d'origine alors voila voila donc valeur
jeu alors est ce qu il faut
effectivement baissé à 50%
notre mix électrique pourquoi pas pas
avec des éoliennes parce qu'on n'a pas à
gâcher le paysage français déjà pour
commencer
deuxièmement je le vois être critiquée
par par michel sapin c'est plutôt bon
signe pour moi d'être critiqué par
un mini skate non québec n'ont qu'à
montrer en tant que les économies sa
médiocrité des résultats pitoyables
donc je pense que monsieur sapin pour
est à vous pourrez pourrait se taire en
fait si vous voulez et pourrait essayer
de comprendre pourquoi il était assis
mauvais ministre pendant si longtemps
je crois que effectivement il fait
preuve de réalisme
il a il il a raison et je ne trouve pas
qu'en fait la vérité et les dialectiques
c'est à dire elle est dans le débat
et pourquoi il y aurait pas un débat au
sein d'un gouvernement il ya eu un débat
est ensuite ya effectivement un premier
ministre et surtout un président franche
c'est tout à fait normal sur st et et
sur la différence entre les ministres et
des journalistes
la différence de nature qu'alexis amble
proposés moi je trouve que je défends
l'éthique d'un journaliste de
responsabilité peut-être que les
journalistes au lieu de voir la
politique au jour le jour à la petite
semaine pourrait aussi considérer la les
les impératifs à très long terme à vingt
ans à 30 ans du développement de notre
pays
ce que j'essaie de faire dans la
chronique internationale pour compléter
cet unanimisme ambiant je propose de
prendre connaissance de la question
qu'ont à poney je vais bien sûr vous
donner la question à d'inutiles inac
poser la donner la parole pardon à denis
tillinac
mais le lecteur du figaro sont assez
content finalement qu'on reporte à 2035
la réduction à 50% du nucléaire dans la
production d'électricité c'est en tout
cas ce que nous répondent nos
internautes
c'est à presque 80 % donc c'est assez
écrasant d'une utilisable par pitié pour
le l'agrément de ce débat dit que vous
n'êtes pas d'accord avec tout ce qui
vient d'être dit bon d'abord mais faites
ce que vous voulez rentrer chose je suis
pas d'accord la plupart du temps avec
des sillons qui sont sista prendre au
gouvernement des gens de la société
civile
il souhaite ça marche pas ça ne marche
pas parce que trop politique c'est un
métier s'implique en règle générale
macro est une exception d'avoir exercé
des responsabilités locales
départementales ministre
ariel haut fonctionnaire on commence à
comprendre ce que c'est que les rouages
d'une société que l'âme d'un pays que
ses ressorts profonds et là on prend une
star de la télé charismatique
indiscutablement avec une sensibilité
écologique sincère il existe maintenant
à l'intérieur de chaque famille
politique de bons spécialistes de
l'écologie
mettons les au gouvernement dans qui
payent ils payent effectivement le la
contradiction entre éthique de
responsabilité éthique de conviction
bon ce serait idiot de l'acculer à
démissionner parce que bon il a fait ce
choix crois pas que ce soit crois pas
que ce soit un bon choix je crois qu'il
va démonétisé sa son image ça va pas
apporter grand chose sur le long terme
au président macron il ya des tas de
grands spécialistes de l'écologie qui
sont aussi capables que l'aude l'exercer
d'être milices de l'écologie vraiment
c'est un tweet je ne veux pas être ne
veut pas être accusée par les autorités
de cette maison et de cette émission que
je que j'aime bien d'être l'avocat
commis d'office de hulot mais quand même
denis souffle souviens toi que hulot
c'est bien sûr un homme issu de la
télévision un haut niveau d'ailleurs
dans tes infos red bull mais par
ailleurs il a été le l'envoyé spécial de
ton ami jacques chirac grotte il a
prononcé ces mots historiques notre
planète brûle et nous détourner les yeux
hulot était avec toi vous étiez ensemble
à johannesburg donc si tu veux la
présence de l'eau j'allais dire dans les
palais de la république n'aurait pas
d'hier dans son rôle de conseiller
par ailleurs et donc et j'en terminerai
la géothermie dans la grâce à ce ce
compagnonnage que tu as sans doute
d'ailleurs contribué à aider je crois
qu'il ya une prise de conscience globale
de la menace écologique planétaire et
des défis qui nous qui nous attendent
mais justement reculer le nucléaire
reculer le nucléaire reculé de new moon
au nucléaire c'est j'allais dire cet
epci launay sq par rapport à l'immensité
de la tâche on maintient le changement
d'accord avec une finale sur le fait
qu'il faut des professions de la
politique si elle était élue députée
enfin cordes conseil municipal m un très
bon tennis a pas étrangère c'est la
première raison et c'est la campagne
pour moi on va voilà merci
la deuxième raison c'est que justement
par prenons le cas de ce monsieur sapin
qui est fait tous les to les étapes
je ne vois pas en quoi cela est mauvais
je n'aurais pas dans la région voilà il
y en a et moi mais je crois que je crois
qu'effectivement il faut c'est utile
d'avoir par exemple la fiscalité
moi je pense pas qu'il faille un
politique ou un haut fonctionnaire pour
la faire je pense qu'il faudra au
contraire prendre un chef d'entreprise
quelqu'un qui connaisse l'économie voilà
mon nom je confonds revenir en exemple
par exemple juppé devient premier
ministre en 97
son premier réflexe aurait 15 du caracal
aurait dû aller voir d'aller voir des dp
multi mais pourquoi expliquez moi
pourquoi vous embauchez pas et on est
passé une semaine dans le cambouis il
aurait expliqué non non non on lui a
expliqué la complexité des déclarations
urssaf chose qui ne comprend pas parce
qu'il a toujours été dans les palais de
l'alhambra
je suis désolé mais je suis désolé à
tous les genres delà de la société
civile dans et le fait que le ministre
blanquer là il vient de la société
civile il a dirigé les sectes et ben je
préfère qu'il est dirigé l'essai qui
fait un très bon ministre l'éducation
qui est été député du puy-de-dôme où
enfin heureusement vous avez pas dit la
corrèze alors on va laisser les cours
on va laisser répondre denis tillinac
moi y'a juste une chose qui je trouve va
à l'appui de ce que dit denis c'est
quand vous avez nicolas hulot qui dit
ben ouais je découvre la complexité pour
se dit quand même ça veut dire qu'il
n'était pas vraiment prêt non oui mais
c'est non je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord avec temps déjà je comprends ce
qui veut dire qu'ils aient la duke et
qu'on adjoignent de temps en temps des
expertises et puis des des gens qui sur
le terrain peuvent apporter des
éclairages d'accord c'est les
complexités tous les emmerdements d'un
pmu ou d'un artisan un truc je suis pays
les connaissez très bien en 95 /
connaissaient ils le connaissent tous
ils sont mieux informés en croit c'est
un peu du poujadisme de dire ils sont
dans leur palais sous les ors ils
connaissent rien à la vraie vie ils la
connaissent très bien
justement parce qu'ils ont des maires
des députés des conseillers généraux
les sénateurs qu'il leur qu'il leur dise
un nom ça je suis pas sûr que tout
simple historiquement ce lien est un
exemple est ce vraiment les
fonctionnements d'économies sur ses pas
du tout mais je vous accorde qu'il y a
des qui a commandé les jeunes qu'ils
aient montré dès qu'il ya des cas où la
société civile ça marche bon c'est
pompidou bien sur ma faim pompidou avait
été au cabinet du général de gaulle dès
la libération il a appris des choses au
conseil d'état est bon après il est allé
dans le privé enfin il se fait quand
même livre mais en règle générale sera
pas marché la société seniran 60 parce
que c'est pas on en profite que dans le
cockpit ou gouverne 2,60 2,67 et se fait
soit clair oui non mais c'est pas bon
c'est l'exemple qui qu'ils plaideraient
pour vous mais ce qui plaide contre vous
c'est le fait c'est vrai qu un
industriel qui va venir avec son
expertise et les sectorielle et en plus
elle est partielle et partiale
quand on prend une décision qui concerne
l'entreprise faut penser aux salariés
faut penser aux syndicats vous pensez
aux cadres faut passer les ouvriers faut
passer aux cadres sup ou repenser aux au
manutentionnaire pensé à tout le monde
faut penser aux relations avec les
collectivités territoriales faut penser
à tout ça et c'est quand même les élus
qui savent mieux tous
ils le sentent le centre je me souviens
de francis marquet les voir le bret
chirac quand il était ministre de
l'économie
et il avait été voir chaque visite était
dicté sa loi il ya un problème avec la
dette qui avait demandé audience au
président et chirac lui avait répondu et
met fin à l'audience immédiatement lv
répondu francis ça fait combien de temps
ça dure ça fait vingt ans ça peut bien
de durer 20 ans et donc la maison si
vous n'êtes pas d'accord fait attention
je crois l'année le denier renault à ne
pas présenter hulot comme une sorte de
bobo déconnecté qu'uniquement créatures
de la télé je crois que c'est faux
depuis longtemps il est autre chose que
ça merci à tous les quatre avaient coûté
jeu on va voir parce que ce sera à mon
avis un feuilleton à épisodes et
notamment ghana qu'on attend d'un
prochain épisode
c'est celui de la viande de notre dame
des landes et ça pour le coup ça
pourrait bien être une à nouveau motif
de tension entre nicolas hulot et le
gouvernement
parlons maintenant si vous le voulez
bien de pierre de villiers pierre de
villiers et l'ancien chef d'état major
des armées françaises vous vous souvenez
sûrement qu'il avait démissionné le 19
juillet dernier pour cause de désaccord
public avec le président de la
république sur le budget qui était celui
de la défense pierre de villiers sort un
livre aujourd'hui qui s'appelle servir
aux éditions fayard et nous rendons
hommage sur ce plateau à alexis lacroix
qui a déjà eu le temps de parcourir
assez largement le livre contrairement à
nous alors une fois n'est pas coutume
alexis vous vous avez la liberté de dire
ce que vous voulez je vais en question
résume une bouquin en 35 secondes je
vais être rapide
je sais une charge bien sûr contre le
sort qu'il a subies mais il a
l'intelligence je crois de ne pas mettre
le curseur de son livre un niveau
personnel
il ne se livre à un règlement de comptes
et voilà il ne se leurrer livre pas un
règlement de comptes a dominé m
d'ailleurs le président de la république
son nom est très peu cités dans ce que
j'ai vu je n'ai pas vu entièrement mais
suffisamment pour m'en rendre compte
et par ailleurs il se réclame comme le
titre l'indiqué d'une éthique du service
qui est propre à l'armée française sans
doute et en particulier mais on peut
penser d'ailleurs plus là
le monde que l'élégance de ce livre est
un livre par ailleurs très dur sur le
fond l'élégance de ce livre n'est pas
sans lien avec les valeurs
aristocratiques dont il se prétend dont
il se prétend l'héritier je vais vous
lire juste une toute petite chose qu'il
dit et qui apparaît quand même comme une
leçon entre les lignes fait au premier
magistrat de france mais aussi peut-être
à l'esprit du temps
il dit oui la grandeur ne se divise pas
la france est grande certes par sa
démographie son économie son agriculture
son industrie s'est armé mais surtout
par cette idée que de gaulle et que le
monde entier sans fond cette idée qui la
singularise et donc à aucun moment dans
cette charge justement contre on va dire
contre les tendances d'aujourd'hui à
dépouiller l'armée de ses oripeaux et
notamment de ses oripeaux financiers il
ne se livre à ce qu'il n'aurait pas dû
faire justement c'est à dire un
règlement de comptes sans élégance une
charge sans élégance comme on en fait
beaucoup aujourd'hui contre des
personnes
et en l'occurrence contre le président
de la république il ne le fait pas et de
ce fait genre j'en termine là guillaume
de ce fait il me semble à cette première
lecture un peu comme ça succincte du
livre qu'il a d'autant plus de force
précisément qu'il ne vise pas un seul
homme même si il ya quand même des
propos qui sont assez claire quand on
veut bien les lire regarder cet extrait
quand on vous montrait la loyauté n'est
pas l'esprit de cour ni la sentiment
permanent à ce qui peut être utile pour
se faire bien voir
le silence est parfois proche de la
lâcheté on va dire que c'est peut-être
un exercice réussi c'est à dire qu' il
dise ce qu'il a à dire sans donner le
sentiment d'être partisan ou de vouloir
prendre sa revanche
même si on sent bien que il a mal vécu
ce moment qui était le 13 juillet quand
la veille du défilé devant tous les
responsables l'armée française et les
armées étrangères a ajouté pierre de
villiers emmanuel macron tance
publiquement
même s'il ne nomme pas son chef d'état
major en disant c'est moi le chef et et
si vous on n'est pas d'accord on se
on se tait marque la première c'est que
le livret semble digne de bon niveau
parce que par exemple il n'explique pas
il ne raconte pas il ne détaille pas la
teneur de son dialogue avec macro et sas
est une ellipse qui est encore plus
ravageuse parce que du coup on soupçonne
que ça a dû être à ça donne l'impression
qu'ils se placent complètement au dessus
de son interlocuteur parce qu'il a même
pas besoin de raconter mais c'est ça
devait pas suffisamment d'un bon niveau
pour qu'il le dise donc ça joue ça assez
digne et en même temps bien bien senti
la deuxième chose c'est que je suis
frappé quand j'écoute alexis cité des
passagers puis joly j'ai vu des extraits
aujourd'hui par la teneur le ton de
jésus général dvd est assez lyriques
c'est un homme qui aime écrire qu'il ne
s'en est jamais caché sa cinquième être
aimé de ses hommes
et c'est un homme qui est aussi un
clivage droite-gauche les a complètement
aboli puisque le lendemain de son
admission libération titrait sur le
départ d'un grand d'un grand homme je
peux quoi c'était donc c'est quand même
trois points communs avec mais le
maquereau donc c'est pas le jeu c'est
pas le nouvel opposant à la macro pour
moi c'est à l'opposé de circonstance l'a
immédiatement mais dans le fond ces deux
hommes n'avaient aucune raison auto
logique ou fondamental de s'opposer et
et voilà ces circonstances qui ont fait
que macro 1 vous lui aurez rétablir une
victime verticale du pouvoir via les
nuits et malheureusement ben voilà est
comme ça entre entre mâcon et villiers
c'est un rendez vous manqué oui on peut
dire que c'est un rendez vous manqué
c'est sûr que pierre de villiers a
toujours voulu défendre le budget des
armées et d'ailleurs pendant la campagne
électorale il voyait des journalistes
par exemple aussi des hommes d'
influence d'un autre type pour défendre
ces 2 % il a eu l'impression 7 % du
budget du rituel du hip état français et
de la france consacré à la défense
et je pense qu'il a raison je pense que
le monde devient de plus en plus
dangereux que l'on pierre de villiers a
raison de dire qu'il est tout à fait
anormal que le budget des armées
qu'en pense d'ailleurs monsieur sympa
que le budget des armées belle saison
dense et non avec je vous montrerai
vous m'avez vous m'avez rappeler son
existence
non je me souviens d'un dîner où je lui
ai fait part du fait que son système
fiscal faisait fuir les entrepreneurs
hors de france et il avait contesté ce
fait nous menons c'était j'exagérais le
phénomène alors que évidemment c'est ce
qu'ils vont montrer qu'ils n'étaient pas
de piquant et encourager des réalités
des réalités alors je reviens au général
de villiers donc je pense qu'il l'a il
est tout à fait raison c'était un homme
proche sata vrai soldat proche de ses
hommes
je pense que alors il est bien sûr que
le le prix dans la république et le chef
des armées
il n'avait pas besoin sans doute
emmanuel macron de le rappeler de
manière si tonitruante parce que tout le
monde
tout le monde le sait je pense que il a
tout à fait tout à fait le droit en
privé enfin en tête à tête de lui faire
des admonestations et des reproches
pierre de villiers a deviné ne m'a pas
parlé il a raison parce que ses couverts
par le secret d'état le secret
professionnel c'est tout à fait normal
ne pas révéler des discussions d'état en
revanche il est il est certain que on ne
on ne fait pas la leçon un homme du type
du général de vider en public peut la
faire en privé on fait un public là je
pense que manuel macro mais qui ne fait
pas de fautes a fait une faute de
commandement voilà ça arrive
mais je pense qu'il va faire il a nommé
d'ailleurs à la place du vin de villiers
un gilles lecointre qui est très bien
qu'il soit excellent oui puisqu'il a
fait en plus qu'on était capitaine un
stage au figaro longs c'est un très bon
un très un très bon choix d'un homme
c'est un il est avec nous il avait
besoin de la houlette de personnes ils
étaient ils étaient ils étaient
intéressés puis revenez couvert de
gloire de sa de ça y est vous il avait
repris avec ses hommes parfois la force
un pont aux milices serbes
il avait fait vraiment la guerre donc le
stade c'est un très bon choix le général
lecointe le général de villiers reste
une personnalité respectée dans l'armée
et a raison dans l'armée et dans la
société française le fait qu'ils ne
choisissent pas fait qui montre qu'il
n'est pas une valérie très tiède trêve
et l'air si vous voulez il ne se venge
pas mais il continue à défendre son
budget et ses valeurs et de dire
effectivement si je m'étais tu seras et
et de la lâcheté je serais resté chez
d'état major mais ce serait de la
lâcheté
c'est tout à son honneur et voilà et je
pense que on peut dire qu'effectivement
c'est un rendez vous manqué mais
heureusement il ya des ressources dans
l'armée nous avons je crois une très
bonne paire aujourd'hui entre emmanuel
macron et son jeune général le coin vous
souhaiteriez vous que pierre david et
s'engage en politique maintenant devront
plus limité une fois de plus serein
premièrement évident que général de
villiers s'est acquis l'estimé et le
respect de tout le monde
au delà de du monde militaire
deuxièmement macro ma croix comme une
faute non pas de commandement mais de
goût or le temps sans publiquement et
puis alors en rappelant puérilement qui
est chef des années c'est écrit dans la
constitution
pas besoin de vous le rappeler c'était
bon et on va dire que c'était une erreur
de jeunesse et sa petite crise d'ado
troisième membre par principe je suis
pas favorable à ce qu'un haut
fonctionnaire ou un conseiller politique
d'un chef d'état ou d'un chef de
gouvernement la peine et quittait ses
fonctions publie des livres et raconte
sa vie je suis pour que les hauts
fonctionnaires y compris à la retraite
restent dans leur coin et respecte le
souvenir
ils ont servi quand ils ont cru devoir
démissionner le fond quelle dignité
comme l'a fait le général de villiers
très bien c'était pas c'était pas la
peine d'en faire plus ça sert à rien la
substance qui dit les valeurs qu'il est
forte on les connaît les a bien défendu
je suis pas favorable ces étalages des
tas d'amis aussi se doute bien qu'il ya
eu des états d'âme le 13 juillet bon ben
salah ça le regarde depuis qu'il garde
ça pour lui même si c'est le premier pas
vu pourquoi pas d'un engagement public
plus affirmée sachant les convictions
qu'il a ça devrait plutôt vous réjouir
cette chose donc on sait pas c'est pas
sûr non plus qu'un haut fonctionnaire
devienne un bon politique ce qu'il veut
ce qu'il veut il
il aurait comme hulot il aurait plus à
perdre qu'à gagner je pense que la
question sur la question de l'engagement
qui sont importantes que vous posez
guillaume elle ne se situe pas tout à
fait dans ce qu'on entend habituellement
mutuellement par un engagement politique
il s'agit plutôt jour droit pour cet
homme qui on l'a bien dit je crois tous
échappe à l'esprit de vengeance à la
bêtise de l'esprit de vengeance dont on
sait depuis le talmud qu'elle est
condamnée par tous les gens qui
réfléchissent à la spiritualité
donc il échappe à ça mais il pose une
pierre je crois sur un chemin qui va
être celui avoir le talmud l'évangile
non mais qui va être celui qui va être
celui oui bien sûr dans de sa part bien
sûr mais qui va être celui de
l'incarnation de certaines valeurs dont
qu'il s'agit pas tellement d'un
engagement politique mais plutôt d'une
sorte d'engagement public
tribunicien pour rappeler à mes rond au
nez rond du moment si vous voulez non
mais il ne manquerait pas des ronds mais
compris pour un peu les comme l'a fait
antigone certaines valeurs au comment
dire à l'empereur ou au président du
moment voilà pour rappeler en fait à
l'autorité publique laïque qui lie à
certaines valeurs plus intemporelle
c'est ça qu'il fait vous voyez est donc
ce à d'autant plus de force précisément
qu'il ne s'agit en aucun cas d'une
charge à dominer mhz contre un
personnage qui serait évidemment comment
dire
maltraité par la part pas par son style
c'est pas du tout le l'objet de la prose
de de villiers là l'objet de la prose de
de villiers c'est de se poser en
défenseur de quelques valeurs
intemporelles plus importante en quelque
sorte que les les enjeux politiques
immédiats et que les quais le colloque
les querelles de basse cour je crois
bien le petit de livres le dit hein
servir c'est un titre c'est un cetain
bottines c'est pas un type de vengeance
ou de d'étalagé aux deux absolument
voilà je vous vois là et le ski est
d'ailleurs intéressant ce que le sujet
inquiète qui avait été qui avait quand
même provoqué sa démission c'est un des
problèmes du budget de la défense
il est toujours pas réglé je propose
d'entendre peut-être en conclusion de
cette partie des missions arnaud danjean
le député européen spécialité des
questions de défense qui dit ben on a
toujours un problème c'est que on n'a
pas assez de moyens
effectivement on a on a des lacunes
on a des lacunes en matière de ce qu'on
appelle les serres intelligence
surveillance et reconnaissance c'est à
dire de renseignement finalement y
compris dans des opérations où nous
sommes en première ligne et où nous
sommes chef de file notamment au sahel
il ya beaucoup de choses que nous ne
pourrions pas faire si nous n'avons pas
l'assistance notamment américaines ça
crée une dépendance pense que cette
dépendance et et problématiques
évidemment elle pèse sur notre capacité
d'action autonome et donc il faut qu'on
réduise je pense cette dépendance
à l'avenir il faut qu'on investisse dans
un certain nombre de moyens qui nous
permettent de plus des plus d'autonomie
dans la gazon qu'encore du grain à
moudre pour le successeur de pierre de
villiers
intéressons nous maintenant à donald
trump le président des états unis
il est en ce moment en asie il était ce
matin à séoul où il s'est adressé
directement à kim jong rhône le leader
bien aimé de la corée du nord pour
renouveler ses menaces ou en tout cas
ces consignes de stricte prudence
regardez alors on va parler de de ce
sujet spécifiquement c'est à dire de la
menace de la corée du nord parce qu'on
en a déjà beaucoup parler mais plutôt à
donald trump lui-même
moi j'imagine déjà les commentateurs
français dit regardez ils favorisent
l'escaladent il est irresponsable c'est
vraiment un mauvais président il est
quand même là depuis un an
on s'aperçoit que il a quand même un
souk de popularité assez fort auprès des
sympathisants républicains de l'ordre de
80% alors et si finalement donald trump
était pas si fragile que ça d'une
utilité et si fragilisés que ça n'est
pas fragilisé aux états unis je pense
que là la base sociologique qui l'a
soutenu qu'il a hissée à la présidence
est toujours là ce sont des ce qu'on
appelle les petits blancs oui c'est les
petits boulots mais au sens au sens
large parce que les petits blancs au
sens du roman de coldwell ça suffirait
pas dieu du sud ont cédé classe c et
classe populaire cds des classes et
laisser les classes moyennes inférieures
certaines minorités
il y en a il y en a qui font que son
discours sa façon de dénoncer qui peut
être perçu comme du politiquement
correct c'est à dire le truc des
intellos de la côte est pour pour faire
vite s'appelait s'appelait assez et je
veux dire il n'est pas du tout prouvé
dans trois ans il sera pas réélu bien
pensé à reggane pensèrent les gammes
comment il était traité par les par les
journalistes et les intellectuels
parisiens espèce de mulets et acteurs de
séries b l'abruti intégral mais il aura
été un grand président on a déjà tout
dit sur la n2 trump la première chose
c'est que la presse américaine qui
finalement au départ a été un peu
sidérée de son élection qui n'est
absolument pas vu venir est obligé
aujourd'hui de s'accrocher aux faits et
de décrire
qui est l'homme par le menu donc c'est
assez intéressant et par ailleurs
j'observe mais renault me conduis très
dira peut-être sur les questions
internationales
le type arrive il est dans les dents les
sujets dans l'est dans les grands
multilatéraux dans les grandes
rencontres multilatérales et dans son
petit coin c'est pas trop ce qu'il va
dire il envoie des tweets un peu bizarre
auger au g20 pour le temps aussi en mai
dernier il est arrivé dans un petit coin
iran ils jouaient pas le jeu du tout du
multilatéral il refusa comme 21 il sort
de l'unesco mais en même temps la petite
pousse pousse ses pions
on voit que le temps il a réussi à
élargir cette autant à toute la zone qui
voulaient défendre il a dit voilà il n'a
pas validé l'article 5 qui dit que tout
le monde de l'otan doit défendre un
autre membre de l'otan s'il est attaqué
il a réussi en fait il pousse son agenda
l'homme était absolument ingérable
personne ne sait comment le manier et en
même temps au bout du compte il sort de
ce sommet où tout le monde ne pense plus
un peu avec des vrais résultats
je voudrais rendre hommage ici à
valentin fils à notre confrère du figaro
points qui a réussi à trouver même en
france sur les réseaux sociaux des gens
qui soutiennent donald trump a continué
valentin oui aussi surprenant que ça
puisse paraître quand on voit les
sondages où la question figaro.fr la
question du jour les internautes qui
défendent le bilan du président
américain sont très nombreux tweets et
commentaires à l'appui on commence avec
le tweet de florian donald trump n'a pas
à avoir honte de ce premier bilan
bien loin des clichés chômage au plus
bas et une croissance à 3%
point négatif juste le côté climatique
enzo renchérit trump a montré en un an
le fruit du protectionnisme aux yeux du
monde entier
chômage en baisse croissance en os made
in you say mise en avant
quoi de mieux pour faire taire les
mondialistes qui était pro clinton nous
dit enzo donatello feu arrêtez avec
votre film sur le hashtag trump un an
nous dit il des centaines de millions
d'américains ont bien soutenu sa cause à
croire le mec il arrivait solitaire au
pouvoir nous dit il un internaute du
figaro faut à même de l'empathie pour le
président américain cette hystérie anti
trump et fatigante
plus on insulte plus je me demande
pourquoi et plus je l'apprécient on
terminera avec ce doublé de hashtag en
référence à donald trump
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui twitter passe à
280 caractère autant vous dire que les
tweets étaient nombreux à ce sujet josé
nous dit trump un an et 280 caractère le
même jour ça fait un peu beaucoup non
et oui trump et twitter une grande
histoire d'amour l'aventuré continue
pour trois ans ou peut-être plus merci
valentin alexis lacroix alors moi j'ai
écouté la chronique de valentin avec
beaucoup d'intérêt toute cette fois ci
m'a pas citer tant mieux d'ailleurs
voilà comme ça je suis anonymisées mais
non j'ai écouté avec beaucoup d'intérêt
je partage la critique de trump si vous
voulez ou donc globalement s'est remise
en cause violent d'ultimes culte du
multilatéralisme et surtout cette
attaque disons à toutes les tentatives
planétaire d'arrêter de freiner le
changement climatique me paraissent
délétère néanmoins qu'est ce que nous
apprend qu est ce que nous apprennent
les messages d'auditeurs de
téléspectateurs que moon est de
collecter c'est qu'à mon avis il ya une
complète innocuité du thon bourrinage du
tintamarre médiatique
moi j'écoute et l'autre jour où la radio
publique 1 j'écoutais le dollar s'est
d'ailleurs dit
ils étaient tous contre treuil alors oui
je suis le premier à une contre-offre
non vers l'été il était père ils étaient
tous ils étaient tous ils étaient tous
côtoient quatre jours at-on m
il était tellement d'idées phantom
altran il était tellement tous contre
trump même à quelqu'un comme moi qui
suis également en titre ' ça donnerait
presque envie de le défendre bien non
c'est pas possible a tellement
d'acharnement et donc j'étais trop petit
pour m'en souvenir mais je pense
qu'effectivement ça rappelle le contexte
d'installation de la présidence reagan
au moment où un certain nombre d'
hystérique gauchistes dénoncé l'
ajustement la mise sous tension du monde
et oui il prend trop au sérieux la
menace soviétique ce connard va
déclencher la guerre etc
cet essai discours là il y avait que
quelques voix à saint germain des prés
et qui vous obsède que quelques voix
pour aller à l'encontre non mais à
l'encontre de sept boxeurs et je réponde
et je pense qu'aujourd'hui je pense
qu'aujourd'hui k'1 k'1 k'1 k'1 ont fait
un peu la même chose c'est à dire que on
ne veut voir dans notre pays sme que les
effets ils ont les plus délétères de la
remise en cause du multi
latéral is et on ne veut pas reconnaître
ce qui ne veut pas dire à désirer trump
ou encore une fois on ne veut pas
reconnaître que par ailleurs qu'un cas
il fait son chemin
peut-être d'ailleurs pour le pire mais
on le présente toujours encore et encore
comme on le présente toujours encore
comme un stagiaire qu'elle n'est plus
depuis longtemps voilà merci renaud
girard 30 secondes pour nous donner
votre point de vue non c'est tout à fait
tout à fait compréhensible que 3 me soit
populaire aux états unis est pas
populaire en europe populaire aux états
unis parce que sur différentes
politiques compris la politique
économique et l'économie se porte bien
aux états unis et puis même sur sa
politique migratoire très strictes si
vous voulez il a beau jeu de critiquer
les démocrates qui avait institué une
sorte de loterie ou n'importe qui
pouvait venir aux états unis grâce à
cette loterie et on est vous avez que
l'auteur du massacre de new york a été
désigné par cette passe est la techno
spec désigné par cette loterie et donc
le peuple américain n'y a là dessus
trump avait raison pourquoi les
européens ne l'aiment pas parce que en
fait trump l'a bien dit d'ailleurs c'est
america farce et défend les intérêts des
américains me défends pas du tout les
intérêts des européens il dit
effectivement
or notre article 5 de l'otan
c'est-à-dire le fait que nous nous
battrons pour vous en toutes
circonstances le bien et je le maintiens
pas forcément c'est un peu ce qui lie
donc voila et des épis et puis pepy
dépenser plus mais sur les européens
pour votre défense on verra après voilà
donc c'est pas très agréable pour les
européens est par ailleurs
commercialement il ne les défend pas il
qu'est-ce qui se passe il fait quelques
arrangements avec la chine qui lui fait
des concessions à lui mais mais pendant
ce temps là la chine elle prend des
positions extrêmement agressive contre
l'europe et des positions en europe un
peu partout l'europe qui est le faible
de ce triangle stratégique me je ne sais
pas quoi répondre
la chine avance en europe elle rachète
des entreprises de technologie en france
où surtout aux mêmes ans
en allemagne et nous ne pouvons pas
résister lui y résiste donc les
européens ont vont en américain qui ne
le défendra absolument pas qui ne
respectent pas le multilatéralisme où
les européens ont les intérêts sont en
iran voilà et donc voilà voilà voilà la
raison
mais effectivement je n'exclus pas du
tout le fait que comme reagan il soirée
du merci beaucoup
apportons un dernier sujet la couverture
de charlie hebdo de cette semaine fait
couler beaucoup d'encre elle montre edwy
plenel directeur de mediapart comme
étant celui qui ne savaient pas qu'ils
ne savaient pas quoi qu'ils ne savaient
pas le la faire ramadan
le prédicateur musulman qui a été
accusée très gravement de viol
d'agression sexuelle est ce que cette
couverture est juste est ce que on peut
accuser de tels inexactitudes de telles
incertitudes plutôt aidé ou pénales et
ben il a répondu ce matin c'était sur
rmc capture c'est aussi notre liberté et
te dire quand la caricature est en fait
un excès un excès de quoi en
l'occurrence de calomnier de dire
n'importe quoi
d'entretenir une cabale et de proférer
des mensonges donc nôtre et notre
réaction est tout simple et les deux
fédérations devant devant cette fait
campagne en fait de lady night s'est pas
complètement faux ce que dit plenel
peut-être parce que on peut l'accuser
d'avoir été proche idéologiquement de
ramadhan d'être avoir été un islamo
gauchistes comme on dit aujourd'hui et
c'est pas pour autant qu'il savait ce
qu'on a reproché aujourd'hui à ramadan a
souvent envie de défendre pleinement je
crois qu'il est de bonne foi tout simple
plenel est toujours de bonne foi il est
convaincu d'être le le coeur vivant de
l'ampleur du bien et de d'être né pour
dire le vrai le beau le veut
le bien et le juste je pense que quand
il laisse entendre que l'année dernière
l'enquêté diligentée médiapart sur tariq
ramadan n'a pas n'a pas décelé des
rumeurs sur lequel c'était un obsédé
sexuel ou un violent sexuel où je suis
voir un violeur pense que se doit de
problèmes parce que personne ne le savez
je n'ai jamais entendu dire moi nulle
peur il ya d'autres personnalités
éminentes qui ont eu de graves problèmes
enfin je veux pas citer personne ça
était de notoriété publique
en tout cas en france depuis 20 ans une
entente mais lui on ne savait pas donc
ça me paraît pas invraisemblable qu'il
n'est pas due alors ce qu'il a dit après
sur l'homme sa façon de percevoir
rabadan quand il l a défendu quand il
l'a n'y ait que quand il a nié le fait
que rabat dans un double langage et puis
qu'il est qu'il est quand même
intellectuellement et moralement douteux
sur le plan de son discours sur la
compatibilité de l'islam et des et des
valeurs occidentales
bon là on peut le critiquer mais pas sur
ce point je pense que je pense
probablement ne seraient pas en tout cas
si d'autres le savez et je dirais tous
les journalistes du monde entier qui
sont coupables si ça savez moi je n'ai
jamais entendu parler moi je vais vous
dire en deux mots je pense que ce débat
dont des se débat dans le débat
évidemment il a lieu est légitime
charlie hebdo versus mediapart c'est un
peu le casting depuis hier mais il est
dommageable car il nous fait passer
quand même à côté de l'essentiel
l'essentiel c'est ce que un historien
néoconservateurs américains avaient
appelé dans les années 2000 veut jeune
holly alliance l'alliance malsaine c'est
l'alliance malsaine entre un certain
nombre d'islamistes et beaucoup de
gauchistes et beaucoup de trotskistes et
donc à essayer de conjecturer sur le
degré de lui
lité éventuel d'eads edwy plenel et de
ses équipes sur les agissements privé de
tariq ramadan
on passe je crois très sincèrement à
côté du vrai sujet qui est de se
demander pourquoi dans les colonnes de
ce journal notamment mais pas seulement
de ce journal dans seulement l'école de
ce pure player mais pas seulement ce
journal il y avait ils ont une présence
importante pendant une quinzaine
d'années qui viennent de s'écouler des
thèses on va dire islamo gauchistes
c'est ça le vrai sujet est donc là je
crains je crains que les gens de charlie
hebdo en déplaçant la focale verbe ce
procès à dominer mme contre edwy plenel
en terre en quelque sorte le seul vrai
sujet d'importance qui est pourquoi
monsieur tariq ramadan depuis plusieurs
années a pris dans la vie publique
française
une telle importance alors que depuis le
livre de fourest son engagement derrière
les thèses meslif lui est ambigu des
frères musulmans n'est une énigme pour
personne c'est ça le vrai sujet et donc
faire dériver
si vous voulez la polémique autour des
agissements personnels aussi grave soit
il de tariq ramadan c'est à mon avis m
la poussière islamo-gauchiste sous le
tapis alexis je me dis juste si qu'elle
nous a observé le spectacle est bon quoi
on voit ces deux médias qui qui
défendent des valeurs républicaines qui
veulent faire le bien comme comme disait
denis on les voit s'entretuer ccc
intéressant d'observer ça mais je me
demande en fait tout ça va je vais j'ai
l'impression que charlie hebdo fait une
couv un peu comme ça gratuitement
volontairement à dominer mais en fait
c'est vrai que si ce pauvre et y doper
n'était pas au courant de ce point-là de
harcèlement c'est l'avocat l'intérêt
c'est désappointant centre le certains
gauchistes européens et notamment
français et
l'islamiste elle remonte à avant ramadan
est toujours sur le bleu d'israël alors
voir mais je veux citer très rapidement
il ya eu le tournant il a raison denis
si on historiciste un peu savoir si edwy
plenel et complice ciblées de tariq
ramadan c'est secondaire
ce qui est important c'est depuis 1967
le tournant historial qui a eu dans les
gauches européennes et américaines qui
sont devenus progressivement fin d'abord
pro-palestiniennes et ensuite pour
certaines pour certains pros islamisme
c'est le cas disons de certaines
fractions des trotskistes européen c'est
ça le vrai sujet et donc si vous voulez
malheureusement cette une qui était
ultra commenté elle nous fait pas passer
à côté de la réflexion vraiment décisive
à mon avis sur cette fracture au sein
des gauches il ya une gauche
démocratique elle existe heureusement en
france aussi mais il ya une gauche qui
par ses fleurs avec les islamistes et
profondément hors du champ de la
démocratie républicaine merci beaucoup
alexis merci à tous les quatre d'avoir
accepté de venir débattre d'un point de
vue eh bien on se retrouve demain même
heure même endroit
bonsoir
[Musique]